we're monsters will help and we call  ourselves the helpsters  it's a delight to see you but i'm afraid  i have a problem  problems are our specialty  if there's a way we'll find it just have  to monster mine from the makers of  sesame street our goal is to teach wayne  a magic trick so he can become a  magician oh we just need a plan i  believe there's an idea inside each and  every one of you what's up i don't get  it he's getting an idea how can  [Music]  for problems big or small let's get this  done they're here to help solve them all  everything is under control everything  is out of control  come quick  high fives and handshakes oh no  we got it wrong we are upstairs and  nobody's giving up not on my watch  [Music]  [Applause]  we did it everyone let the jubilations  commence  that means be happy  helpsters  watch now on the apple tv app